bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir
nous allons parler d'un projet important
un projet qui va structurer le
territoire des yvelines et saint quentin
pour les années à venir voire même les
décennies un projet qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre du grand paris il s'agit de la
ligne 18 le futur métro qui reliera à
l'horizon 2030 l'aéroport d'orly à la
gare de versailles chantiers en passant
par saint quentin en yvelines c'est un
enjeu majeur pour l'économie la
recherche la formation et c'est un enjeu
qui fait débat également plusieurs
collectifs associations mêmes partis
politiques demandent une révision totale
ou partielle du projet pour en parler ce
soir bertrand ou lyon le maire
socialiste de magny les hameaux
guillaume sebileau le président de
l'adav l'association de protection des
droits des habitants de voisins et de
ses environs et françois bellini
trésorier de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles yvelines
bonsoir à tous les trois et avant de
commencer cette émission je tiens à
préciser également que nous avons
sollicité plusieurs fois la société du
grand paris en charge de ce projet pour
participer évidemment à cette émission
malheureusement celle-ci a refusé ne
souhaitant pas débattre pendant l'
enquête publique qui court jusqu'au 26
avril forcément c'est regrettable nous
avons tenté de vous aider à mieux
comprendre les enjeux de cette future
ligne et d'ailleurs nous sommes allés à
votre rencontre vous demander ce que
vous en pensiez de cette ligne 18 on
écoute vos réponses les réponses des
saint quentinois
bon je sens que c'est pas mal on est
dans la région mais assez relativement
mal desservies donc ce qu'on veut des
dents dehors de mes préoccupations en
habite dans le quartier de la bretagne
bien sûr ça nous embête un peu quand
même la terre bouge sans arrêt et
résultat vaudrait mieux que ça passe
ailleurs quand même un accès très bien
parce que sur cette clé yahoo a pas de
communication
ça peut amener plus de monde ça peut
faciliter
les voyages pour les gens qui vont
travailler enfin voilà donc après mais
bon c'est vrai que ce serait dommage
dénaturer le paysage comme c'est vrai
que nous un truc aller ailleurs c'est un
plus pour tout le monde il me semble et
la valeur de nos maisons sa note alors
vous l'avez entendu des réactions plutôt
partagés avec une tendance tout de même
assez positif sur cette future ligne de
métro françois bellini vous représentant
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
des yvelines telle est votre avis sur le
sujet c'est un projet primordial
aujourd'hui pour vous c'est clairement
une priorité est clairement une priorité
aujourd'hui nous avons un axe entre le
yen paris sat l'aide ça te laisse
jusqu'à saint quentin en yvelines où
nous avons les études les recherches
fondamentales côté s'attelait nous avons
les entreprises les salariés les
recherches privées côté saint quentin et
on a besoin d'une colonne vertébrale et
il est clair que la ligne 18 et cette
colonne vertébrale dont on a besoin pour
aller de saint quentin à saclay ça va
permettre aussi de ramener de nouvelles
entreprises sur le territoire de créer
des emplois sur vous ça permet de
fluidifier les trajets des personnes et
des personnels sur les différents
territoires ça et ça permet également de
rapprocher les entreprises sur le
territoire
si on a la ligne 18 on n'est pas du tout
dans le même contexte si on est isolé
comme on l'a aujourd'hui au niveau du
transport donc un des enjeux c'est d'une
part l'implantation des entreprises
extérieures sur saint quentin et où
s'attelait là en l'occurrence saint
quentin mais l'autre enjeu c'est le fait
d'avoir d'autres lignes présentes autour
de paris qui sont en train de
s'installer qui sont en train de se
construire
peut-être qu'il faut pas oublier que les
entreprises qui sont ici notamment les
grosses entreprises et risquent de
partir et quelque part c'est aussi le
travail de nos enfants berthon lyon en
qualité de maire de magny également de
conseiller communautaire qui est votre
avis sur cette ligne alors déjà d'un
point de vue
général est ce que vous êtes favorable à
cette ligne ce que je sais aussi que
vous êtes défavorable à une partie du
tracé de l'année je me suis déjà exprimé
plein de fois clairement par rapport à
par rapport à tout ça c'est une épine
dorsale comme comme vous le dites c'est
une nécessité par rapport au pôle
économique qui est saint quentin en
yvelines mais aussi au pôle d'habitat
qui est saint quentin en yvelines
l'objectif premier des transports est
bien de relier les habitants à leur lieu
de travail alors lieu de loisirs de
manière générale à facilités à
fluidifier les transports
on sait que à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu comme une
maison autour de laquelle il y a aucun
accès piéton ou voiture et c'est parce
qu'on est totalement engorgé
donc c'est une ville nouvelle qui s'est
bien constituer à l'intérieur qui est
devenu le deuxième pôle économique d'île
de france qui a un habitat diversifié
qui qui a un aménagement intéressant
mais qui a une grosse problématique
c'est que on est totalement fermée
aujourd'hui et il suffit de regarder le
matin quand on veut aller vers paris ou
inversement
c'est totalement impossible et les
durées de trajet pour aller à paris
dépasse leur ce soit en transport ou ou
en voiture donc on a besoin de cette
épine dorsale qui en plus leur
rapprochement finalement entre
l'ensemble des parties de l'opération
d'intérêt national paris saclay donc
c'est c'est majeur aujourd'hui malgré
cela pour vous pour la commune de magny
les hameaux ce qui ce qui vous dérange
aujourd'hui c'est le passage en viaduc
d'une partie de cette ligne 14 km sur
les 35 que fait la ligne
qu'est ce qui est et ce qui me dérange
le plus dans ce passage en viaduc
une fois qu'on sait qu'il que ça fait 40
ans 50 ans qu'on attend des solutions de
transport viable pour l'ensemble des
habitants
il ne faut pas que ces solutions de
transport
aïe aussi à l'encontre finalement dû
de ce qu'attendent les habitants et que
ça devienne un transport nuisibles donc
là dessus il est indispensable visible
en termes de ventes et remet en termes
sonore en terme de paysage on est à
l'entrée du parc naturel régional aux
ayvelles chevreuse on sait aujourd'hui
les techniques qui existent pour avoir
des transports qui soit fluide et qu'il
ne soit pas qui n'est pas de nuisances
pour les riverains
on sait faire donc faisons le sachant
qu'en plus sur le reste de la ligne et
puis sur d'autres secteurs du grand
paris c'est déjà fait et en plus en 2011
ça devait être totalement souterrain
donc aujourd'hui nous ce qu'on demande
c'est tout simplement que ce besoin de
transport qui est totalement
indispensable ne viennent pas finalement
sacrifié un certain nombre de
territoires qui sont nos territoires
ruraux
les habitants de ces territoires ruraux
les agriculteurs aussi de ces
territoires ruraux projet aujourd'hui
enfin le projet le projet actuel en tout
cas tel qu'il est présenté ça fait de
vous en opposant on est tout simplement
pour la ligne 18 et qu'elle soit en vie
ces terres qu'elle n'ait pas de
nuisances pour les riverains qui
attendent ceux qui attendent des
solutions transport depuis longtemps
mais pas uniquement la gué 18 on attend
d'autres secteurs la tangentielle ouest
on en attend d'autres
d'autres éléments de transport comme
dédoublement de voirie comme des
transports en commun en site propre qui
ont été réalisés à saint quentin en
yvelines depuis des années et dont ils
manquent le tronçon toujours le même ce
tronçon qui doit nous permettre d'aller
vers saclay donc il faut vraiment
réussir aujourd'hui à faire cette
révolution de transport en quelque sorte
qui permettent de donner des
alternatives aux véhicules particuliers
c'est indispensable aujourd'hui pour le
développement économique de notre de
notre comité d'agglomération mais aussi
pour le développement durable tout
simplement de l'aménagement de nos cités
guillaume c'est bio vous représentez
vous un quartier de la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux le quartier de la
bretonnière est-il vous dérange vous ce
n'est pas le passage en aérien du métro
au contraire c'est le passage sous votre
quartier du métro vous dites que
clairement c'est dangereux pour vos
maisons en fait le tunnel à cet endroit
là il est une très faible profondeur
puisqu'il se trouve à 15 mètres du sol
le toit du tunnel se trouve à 15 mètres
alors qu'ils devraient se trouver sur
les autres tronçons en souterrain à plus
de 25 mètres
donc ça ça pose déjà un problème de
nuisances puisque l'habitat est
constitué de maisons qui sont quasiment
toutes de plain pied se sont pas des
immeubles de grande hauteur
donc c'est un habitat qui est
extrêmement sensible aux vibrations et
au bruit solidien alors de plus ce
quartier a été construit sur des sols
qui sont à tendance forte argileuse et
qui sont très soumis
dition climatique de sécheresse et de
pluies qui provoquent des gonflements
entrait donc même question que pour
bertrand lyon vous êtes vous favorable à
l'innovation au tracé la manipulation ce
que ceux ci voulaient ce qu'on en solo
qu'on constate aussi bien pour le le
tracé sur le plateau que au niveau de la
bretonnière c'est qui semble que les
études d'impact n'ait pas été effectué
hier qu'on n'a pas fait la les yeux paix
n'a pas fait d'études d'impact pour voir
si ça posait un problème de passer à cet
endroit là est ce que ea non dans la
quête publique on constate qu'il ya une
école elle n'est pas répertorié et le
tracé passe au droit de cette école
maternelle donc si vous voulez qu'on
constate c'est que les gens qui ont qui
ont conçu ce tracé n'ont pas fait les
études nécessaires pour vérifier
l'impact aujourd'hui que ce soit à
manier ou votre quartier avoua voisins
ce que vous discutez avec la société du
grand paris est ce que vous êtes entendu
où en sont les discussions si vous
discutez avec eux l'atr aurions la
société du grand paris on parle avec eux
on peut pas forcément par les dialogues
entre qu'on leur dise qu'on en pense
depuis alors mode depuis que je suis élu
maire dont depuis 2012
je les ai rencontrés régulièrement on
leur explique les raisons qui font que
l'on souhaite que l'enfouissement soit
maintenue finalement puisqu'il était à
la base et les raisons pour lesquelles
on le demande comme nos collègues de
châteaufort ville et le bag le sac les
c'est simple il les explique
ils ont fait une grande concertation
tous les élus simplement à chaque
réunion qu'on peut avoir avec eux on
leur explique
on leur donne le sentiment des élus de
terrain que nous sommes donc des
habitants
en leur expliquant très clairement à
chaque fois que c'est une épine dorsale
indispensable mais qu'elle ne doit pas
apporté de nuisances aux riverains et
qu'il y a les solutions techniques qui
existent simplement à chaque fois c'est
une fin de non-recevoir ils restent sur
leur sur leur système largement en tout
cas pour manier les mots c'est le coût
que supposerait d'enfouir le métro 205
millions d'euros en plus c'est même pas
l'argument puisque cet argument là ils
nous l'ont trouvée ya à peine un an par
rapport à toutes les demandes qu'on
avait fait d'études de chiffrage d'étude
d'impact et c'est là par exemple pour
vous donner juste un exemple le le
dernier élément en date juste avant le
démarrage de l'enquète public
je les rencontre une nouvelle fois et on
m'explique pour manille ça va aller
mieux l'enfouissement parce qu'en fait
les monuments nous ont demandé que ça ne
passe pas devant la porte de mes rentes
et qui est sur le golf qui est un
élément un élément classe et de
monuments historiques qui est sûre donc
il est l'ancien porte du parc du château
de versailles qui a été refaite
récemment et donc du coup ils vont
offrir plutôt pour une porte derrière
laquelle il n'y a personne
alors il faut protéger nos monuments
historiques mais il faut aussi protéger
les populations et ça par contre ils
oublient toujours et guillaume sellier ô
vous les discussions sur le quartier de
la bretonnière ça semble plutôt
optimiste quand on va aux réunions
publiques
on croit comprendre peut-être un nouveau
tracé va se dégager
parce que il ya des choses comme ça qui
se disent ils le disent en public mais
on n'a aucun écrit on manque des cris on
manque d'engagement et donc aujourd'hui
pour nous on
on n'a pas évolué dans la situation
depuis un an on en est toujours au même
point qu'on nous promet des choses on
nous a dit on a bien pris en compte
votre problématique on sait qu'il ya des
problèmes il ya des problèmes techniques
à la bretonnière donc on va voir on va
faire tout ce qu'il faut pour passer
sous le golfe
mais aujourd'hui tant que l' enquête
publique n'est pas terminé on n'a aucune
assurance que ça sur le cas françois
bellini tous ces problèmes locaux ne
concerne pas directement évidemment la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles des volumes est ce que ça
vous inquiète et éventuellement sur un
report est ce que ça pourrait engendrer
un report ce selon vous est ce que ça
vous inquiète ça il faut savoir quand
même que les thèmes locaux tout tout ce
qui concerne ce que vous appelez les
problèmes locaux sur des problèmes
souvent de salariés vous êtes à hama les
territoires et les entreprises sont
concernées par les salariés ça c'est le
premier point après effectivement la
priorité de la chambre de commerce est
que cette ligne se fasse ça c'est très
clair
j'entends que finalement tout le monde
est favorable à la ligne 18 donc ya pas
de problème de fond sur la ligne 18 par
contre si on comprend bien les
problématiques liées à la main à la mise
en place de cette ligne donc peut-être
qu'il faut effectivement travaillé sur
le
sur la partie bretonnière et demandé à
la société grand pari de changer dès le
passage souterrain alors je sais pas
après sur manille je suis pas un grand
spécialiste ès que des des systèmes liés
à l'économie nuit la nuisance sonore
pourrait répondre à la demande ou pas
est-ce que le fait qu'on demande ça peut
être un peut avoir un impact positif ou
est ce que vous demandez de façon
définitive à enfouir lola une bonne
question
c'est un enfouissement tout simplement
parce que il suffit de regarder
l'histoire des des axes structurants
qu'on connaît ne serait-ce qu'en ile de
france et est tout ce qu'on est en train
de fuir aujourd'hui parce que obligé de
protéger à grands coups parce que ça n'a
pas été pensé avant là on a alors un
chiffre qui a été sorti dernièrement par
la sgp qu'on conteste pas ce que
ce chiffre là sur le gouvernement oui
sur le coût de l'enfouissement sur cette
partie de ligne parce que nous on n'a
rien aux futurs enseignants l'euro mais
bon de toute façon ça ne représente même
si on partait sur les 250 millions
d'euros
ça ne représente que 0 8% du coût de
l'ensemble du métro grand paris de
remplacer milliards d'euros la limite ça
coûtera peu près 3 milliards d'euros
c'est ça fait 6 ou 10 % de ce total là
si on reste sur la ligne par rapport à
un tel investissement sur forcément un
emprunt qui va être sur des années un
axe structurant si on prend l'exemple du
métro qui est sur une centaine d'années
qu'est ce que c'est c'est la largeur du
trait tout simplement
donc à partir de ce moment là que l'on
fasse le nécessaire pour que vraiment
cette ligne répondent aux besoins et
même aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qui se
fait sur 50 ans divine je ne suis pas
certain qu'on réponde aux besoins
donc il faut réussir à répondre aux
besoins et d'autre part réussir à ce que
ce besoin ne soit pas une nuisance pour
ces mêmes personnes qui vont devoir le
prendre quand je dis que ça on n'est pas
sûr que ça ne répond pas aux besoins
ça fait pareil plus de quatre ans que je
demande qu'il y ait des études sur
l'intermodalité haut niveau notamment
des dépôts le gard c'est à dire qu'on
puisse assurer préfigurer les accès à
ces pôles gars qui sont indispensables
parce que si on fait un métro auquel on
peut pas accéder ce métro ne servira à
rien il faudrait les cantons s'est
réparti les facs des parkings des axes
aussi structurant de transport en commun
pour des actes de rabattement vers ces
gars quand on sait comment
notre commune et la zone tampon entre le
sud des yvelines et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vélizy et
palaiseau mais aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
puisse avoir des réponses dans sud des
yvelines pour pouvoir accéder à ces
pôles gars qui seront des appels d'air
et ça aujourd'hui pareil ça fait ça fait
partie des choses sur lesquelles nous
n'avons pas de réponse c'est bio vous un
problème qui dure depuis la construction
de la ville nouvelle c'est le contrôle
mans sud de voisins-le-bretonneux kiné
qui n'est pas réglé c'est à dire que
vous avez un flot de voitures qui
traversent voisins on rappelle ainsi au
milieu de l'agglomération saint quentin
c'est disons dans le sud un c'est
l'extrême sud troisième marquis tampon
avec magny les hameaux voilà exactement
bon aujourd'hui si vous voulez l'iman
qui manque ce contournement de voisins
parce que toute la circulation passe par
magny les hameaux par voisins bretons ne
traversent les petites rues de voisins
et l'apport d'une gare va faire venir
énormément de voitures les gp n'a pas
prévu de parking la gare de
saint-quentin est et ce problème ne
compte quand on ne ment n'est pas réglé
donc ça s'il voulait céder millions
d'heures de travail perdues tous les
matins par des gens et tous les soirs
par des gens qui viennent de dampierre
qui viennent du sud des yvelines de
l'essonne et qui veulent passer françois
bellini vous est d'ailleurs intervenu
durant là la réunion publique est en
cours sur ce problème des parkings
il me semble quand même qu'on a entendu
parler de parking sur sur saint-quentin
donc en tout cas au niveau de la chambre
de commerce
il doit faire sens d'ailleurs des
parties n'est pas ce qu'on peut imaginer
des énormes il faut les énormes espace
n'est pas sûr d'y arriver est parti
aujourd'hui et la multimodalité est un
point important également effectivement
on demande ces deux points les parkings
et allemand ce sont souvent les parents
pauvres
de ce type de projet mais qu'il faut
absolument intégrer dans ses projets il
ya un autre une autre problématique
aujourd'hui sur cette ligne 18 en tout
cas vous l'avez également souligné
françois améli ni pendant la réunion
publique c'est que cette ligne va se
faire en deux étapes une première étape
qui concerne pas forcément directement
les yvelines avec en 2024 un premier
tronçon d'orly à saint-aubin puis en
une mise en service de saint-aubin à la
gare de versailles donc en gros on va
avoir cette ligne 18 qui arriverait à
saint-quentin uniquement en 2030 vous
françois bleynie vous dénoncez ce
calendrier vous dites on peut et on doit
aller plus vite
oui tout à fait il me semble clairement
que le problème n'est pas un problème
technique que le problème est clairement
une preuve de décision donc nous
demandent à ce que cette ligne 18 ch
soit fait en totalité en 2024
qu'il y ait ou non d'ailleurs les jeux
olympiques les jeux olympiques peuvent
être un prétexte un accélérateur mais
que les jeux olympiques pourraient
arriver on va dire en force à saint
quentin en yvelines avec le golfe oui
c'est de justifier avec les jeux
olympiques mais mais pas seulement ces
questions c'est qu'une question de
l'activité de business 2030 j'ai
tendance à dire que c'est une éternité
pour une entreprise on n'a pas de
visibilité à 2030 dans une entreprise
même les grosses à 2024 on commence à
voir des choses on peut imaginer des
déménagements pays magique imaginé de
s'installer sur un site mais à 2030 on
prend pas de décision donc si on veut
attirer les entreprises sur saint
quentin en yvelines on n'a pas le choix
il faut que cette ligne soit quels sont
vos moyens d'action sur ce sujet là de
donner notre avis de discuter
régulièrement avec la société gros pari
d'être présent et différentes
commissions
voilà berton millions sur ce calendrier
là vous partager le point de vue en tant
qu élu communautaire il faut que la gare
arrive en 2024 à 50 ha enfin de toute
façon on a déjà 40 ans de retard sur sur
un axe structurant sage en plus rares
sur cette partie là si c'est grave mais
mes 40 ans de retard c'est déjà grave on
aurait déjà dû avoir depuis des dizaines
d'années un transport en commun en site
propre qui aurait déjà pu régler un
certain nombre d'éléments on aurait déjà
dû avoir le doublement de cette voirie
la rd36 pour régler aussi un certain
nombre de désagréments
ce métro structurant avec ces
abattements justement possible par par
tcsp avec un rabattement possible
totalement nécessaire pour
l'intermodalité avec les autres gars de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est des éléments qui sont qui sont
indispensables qui me semble pas
aujourd'hui totalement travaillé par
rapport au projet qui est présentée
vraiment pour moi c'est une vraie des
espèces déception en fait c'est à dire
que on
on sait tous au niveau du terrain la
nécessité de cet axe structurant et de
des rabattements en intermodalité à
partir de l'ensemble de l'existant on
sait tous au niveau du terrain
simplement on est arrivé avec une
société du grand paris
qui a lancé comme ça un projet
totalement hors sol sans connaître ne
serait-ce que shoya de de notre
territoire et qui reste concentré sur sa
ligne de conduite qui reste au sol
donc à partir de ce moment là forcément
on va jamais réussir à avancer alors que
c'est quelque chose qui est totalement
nécessaire et 2024 c'est de toute façon
déjà trop tard etc et toutes les
entreprises qui viennent sur 50 ans
divine nous le disent sur ma commune
j'ai la chance d'accueillir safran qui
se développe avec l'ensemble de ses
laboratoires
première question qui nous ont posé
c'est comment on fait pour pouvoir
accéder comment on fait pour pouvoir
venir travailler au delà du
rapprochement habitants au poids il faut
que les gens puissent bouger dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
je vous propose maintenant d'écouter à
un nouvel avis puisque ici on est tous
favorables à la ligne la ligne 18 en
tout cas vous juliette s knitter elle
est conseillère municipale d'europe
écologie les verts et guyancourt
elle et son parti s'oppose totalement au
projet écoutez nous écologistes nous
sommes opposés à ces crimes 18 nous
sommes pour des transports en commun
mais des transports en commun efficaces
qui répondent aux besoins de la
population et en l'occurrence et dim 18
va pas y répondre elle est
surdimensionné c'est un énorme
investissement 4 milliards d'euros qui
traverse une zone désertique une zone
des chambres dans lequel n'y a pas de
pas de logement et du coup il n'y a pas
de ya pas de population qui va aller sur
ces crimes 18 et
en fait c'est 18 elle a pour objectif de
faire de la spéculation immobilière
l'idc ont construit une ligne un métro
et on y re banier autour on demande de
la rénovation deux de nos transports
cela le rer b pour mettre un tramway il
a faim il ya tout un tas de solutions
qui ont pas été étudiée qui répondraient
beaucoup plus aux besoins de la
population et c'est ça que nous
demandons alors je vais vous faire
réagir tous les trois sur ce qui vient
d'être dit on va commencer par vous
guillaume c'est bio projet
surdimensionné spéculation immobilière
on pourrait faire tout aussi bien avec
les moyens de transport que l'on a
aujourd'hui si on les améliore est ce
que vous partagez certains de ses points
de vue en fait nous ce qu'on constate
c'est que c'est un projet qui n'est pas
tel qui n'est pas fini parce que le
problème de la gare de saint-quentin est
en fait cette gare elle dessert 10
heures aujourd'hui des principalement
des zones d'habitation puisqu'on sait
très bien que les gens qui travaillent
au technocentre n'utilisent pas les
transports en commun ces gens qui
viennent en voiture travailleurs
voitures principalement et que en fait
il aurait fallu aller jusqu'au bout et
il aurait fallu que cette cette ligne 18
pénètre jusque dans le centre de saint
quentin pour assurer l'interconnexion
avec les moyens de transport existants
la future radial qui doit se développer
aussi vers le nord donc voilà france un
bellini est ce que le territoire des
yvelines et de saint-quentin pourrait
continuer à se développer économiquement
sans cette ligne 18 en améliorant les
transports à te oui oui bien sûr mais
moins vite moins vite l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est on a parlé tout à
l'heure le yen paris saclay est
considéré comme territoire majeur
on va avoir le plus grand pôle
universitaire en europe sur s'attelait
on va voir toute la recherche
fondamentale sur s'attelait on a les
entreprises qui sont ici j'ai tendance à
dire régulièrement que si la mayonnaise
apprend pas entre en termes d'activité
des entreprises vis-à-vis de la
recherche on n'y arrivera pas c'est pas
c'est pas la réussite si on n'a pas ça
donc
la ligne 18 pour nous est un outil
majeur permettant de le faire mais c'est
pas uniquement ça qui va permettre de le
faire c'est l'ensemble tout de tous les
projets qui vont être mises en place sur
st quentin mes retrouvailles on vous
avez la chance de conclure cette
émission votre avis rossi avoue sûr sûr
sûr ce qui a été dit à l'instant on
pourrait faire le territoire sans cette
ligne 18 et puis aussi sur la
spéculation immobilière est ce que c'est
un sujet qui peut vous inquiétez vous
aussi la des aspects de désert qui
remercie l'intervenante qu'on a entendu
puisque je fais partie d'une partie du
désert traversé cette ligne 18 pour moi
aujourd'hui est fondamental je le répète
mais elle ne peut pas être tout seul un
axe structurant une colonne vertébrale
elle n'existe pas elle ne sert à rien
s'il n'ya pas le reste est donc cette
colonne vertébrale ne peut servir que si
il y à l'intermodalité que si il y à la
construction aussi de l'ensemble des
autres modes de transport complémentaire
qui doivent s'ajouter tout le sud
yvelines doit pouvoir est irriguée par
des modes de transport complémentaire
alternatifs au véhicule particulier pour
éviter l' asphyxie
on doit pouvoir travailler sur un centre
de route notamment l'air des 36 devrait
être être doublé c'est complémentaire
il faut que nous puissions travailler
également sur la restructuration de la
ligne du rer b qui doit être
complémentaire de cette ligne 18 la
tangentielle ouest doit pouvoir doit
pouvoir raccrocher et les liens entre
les pôles
des épaules gare de 50 ans divine est
absolument fondamentale
donc tous ces éléments là sont des
éléments complémentaires de cette ligne
mais qui je le rappelle pour être
efficace cette ligne doit pouvoir
permettre à l'ensemble des habitants d'y
accéder donc d'accéder au pôle gare par
ces complémentarités et elle ne doit pas
apporté de nuisance complémentaires par
rapport à l'existant
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à cette émission et vous pouvez
participer encore à l' enquête publique
sur la ligne 18 via le site internet
enquête publique ligne 18 point fr et
cette émission est à retrouver également
rappelé sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne
soirée à tous